[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jon's
with us in Jackson New Hampshire hi
Janie how are
you well as you said better than I
deserve much better good how can we help
today well and my dad used to say advice
is worth what you pay for it so that was
fun to start the show off with that okay
so I uh my daughter's two 40ish years
old daughters and I co-own a cabin
that's uh across the road from my house
where I I've lived at this house for 40
years and um we bought the cabin five
years ago we're all three on the
deed and as he said a few weeks ago
never go into business with anyone one
reason being that they will have
different
interests from you and that's what we're
facing um I'd like Tove move from my
home to the cabin um which needs some
serious work to make it
livable um and my daughters one of them
wants to just do as little as possible
and make it into a seasonal
rental and the other one wants that also
but she doesn't want me to have a home
there because she can deny
it uh because we all have to agree since
we're
co-owners um we all have to agree on
work done there and about 20 years ago
she was doing a bunch of bad stuff and I
had told her if you keep this up you're
going to have to leave so I had to kick
her out of the house and she wants to
punish me for that so the way you the
why you hand that she you have a
daughter that wants to punish you and
you decide to buy a cabin with
her it wasn't um it
wasn't bought the cabin five years ago
20 years ago you kicked her out
well five years ago when the cabin came
up for sale um the
owner wanted to sell it to my
daughters and so they on paper bought it
I paid 200,000 for it um so I paid for
the taxes and the purchase price and all
of the repairs that we have done um so
they put no money in Money
in excuse me they put no money in
right oh gosh and I bought my
house and do you guys have any kind of
written agreement on this at
all we have one agreement that they came
up with that says we all have to agree
on any work that's done did you sign
that yes
why why did you I don't know I don't
know why you did any of this if you had
$200,000 buy the cabin don't buy the
cabin why did you put them on on here
knowing that this is going to be that
this one daughter is going to be a
problem from day one I didn't I didn't
know that and that yeah you did would
not sell it to me alone she wanted to
sell it to my daughters why so I had no
we either wouldn't get the cabin yeah or
the girls would both be on the de what
what was initially the use of the cabin
when you first bought it did you buy it
because you said you know what I'm going
to move in here and everybody knew that
or was the initial purpose of the cabin
to rent it out to someone someone
else it was me moving up there was an
option um we didn't talk about any plans
I started doing little bits here and
there having a cabin chinked making sure
the roof was good okay joh let me ask
you this how how old are you I bought it
to I bought it to protect the value of
my house um so that we're surrounded by
national forest and it's I bought my
house for 29 ,000 now it's worth a
million Joanie how old are
you 70 70 okay you have made a
mess that's right this is a mess okay
and you're really left with only a
couple of options uh one is to convince
your daughters to deed the property over
to you given that they put no money in
it to start with and they have no rights
to this morally or ethically MH okay
this is an absurd deal you should not
have done this deal it was a dumb deal
it was a bad deal you set yourself up to
get punched in the nose now you're
getting punched in the nose so now the
only thing you can do with this is you
can convince them to deed it over to you
or you can hire an attorney and sue them
and force the sale of the cabin and show
the judge that they put 0 into this and
that at least you get your $ 200,000
back before there's anything split at
the sale now you get to decide are are
you going to be able to convince them
that you guys are all stupid what you've
done here is all stupid you're not
stupid but what you've done is
ridiculous it's a horrible plan and your
daughters are horrible that they took a
third of this knowing that they didn't
get along with their 70-year-old mother
and she paid 100% of it that's kind of
like being a thief
okay that's kind of what that's like so
I don't really like your daughters much
and this is not going to be easy and so
I don't know that you're going to be
able to convince these two dweebs to
turn the thing over to you and I'm
afraid you're going to be faced with a
judge to do it or you've just gotten
screwed out of 200,000 because you've
lost control of this because you've got
a two to one vote and the deed doesn't
have any restrictions on it whatsoever
you've got three people and they have
two of the
votes so uh but but a judge can untangle
this and the a judge can force the sale
of the of of the cabin and give you
$200,000 at the sale one other option on
the persuasion side you could do is you
can offer the dweeb some money to go
away I'll give you $25,000 a piece if
you've got it or whatever to sign the
deed over to me gosh which is immoral
yeah thievery blackmail whatever you
want to call it but you it's going to be
cheaper than core mhm she's not going to
like them much after that though well I
don't like them so it's easy to not like
them yeah I mean they're not likable
that's right who does this to their
parent I don't know it's weird you threw
me out of the house 20 years ago I'm
going to get back at you I'm going to
get you to pay full price for a cabin
that I own onethird of and then I'm not
going to let you do anything good God
this is terrible four-year-old is this
needs counseling unbelievable so yeah
some people's children but the um yeah
guys you cannot enter into these things
wide eyed open and expect you know a
crocodile to do anything but bite your
leg off crocodiles is what they do I
just can't understand the I even even if
they liked each other right what would
be ever the purpose of going into
something like it it makes no sense if
she was going to move into it anyway
just buy the house for herself well the
guy wouldn't sell it to her which is
weird that's weird too there's a lot of
weird here but yeah H Johnny I'm sorry I
wish I had a magic wand to make your
pain go away but your pain is not a
cabin your pain is your daughter's mhm
and that's what you're going to have to
deal with one way another probably the
cheapest way to do this is just buy the
dweebs out and get them to sign it over
just you know it's a dweeb fee it's a
stupid tax fee and I do something stupid
and it cost me money Johnny I call it
stupid tax you're probably going to pay
some stupid tax here you are going to
pay some stupid tax they better not ask
for a third you're going to pay a lawyer
well they'll ask for it you know these
you're going either pay a lawyer you're
going to pay the dweebs or you're going
to lose your 200,000 these are your
three way but you're going to lose money
you're going to lose money something
something's going on here I'm paying a
lawyer that if if it's me I'm paying a
lawyer I don't I don't want to fool with
these girls anymore wow it's your kids
they're
dweebs